let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well good afternoon everybody
i have a special treat for you
today we have a special guest
here on let's talk the tony michaels
podcast
a lot of you out there on twitter and
tick tock
instagram and youtube know who i'm
talking about
it is anthony c walker
the hot medic some of you know him as
hot medic i mean you know
i think he's pretty hot i'd do him i
mean you know what
you're into that kind of thing but
he's here on the podcast today we get to
interview him we get to talk to him
i want to ask him about the videos i
want to ask him but where he gets all
this manga [ __ ] do you have to buy all
this [ __ ] manga stuff
and have the posters and the [ __ ]
hats and [ __ ] laying around
make me want to barf i'd burn all that
[ __ ]
but somehow this guy keeps it around so
he can make uh videos and keep us
entertained
so we're going to ask him about that
we're going to ask him about a few other
things too
but i want to show you a little bit of
video of anthony c
walker the hot medic i want to show you
the kind of content that he makes
because it's very interesting content a
lot of people are confused
some people are this guy's a manga this
guy is one of them queueing on [ __ ]
no no it's just satire people it is just
satire hey tic tocs algorithm he's just
pretending to be an idiot
he's not really a [ __ ] idiot well i
mean
he might be but he's pretending to be
one
so we got anthony c walker here today
on the tony michaels podcast now you
notice it's not live today we had to do
a recording
but we're making it work and anthony
decided that he would be on the very
first recorded episode
of the tony michaels podcast and i think
we're going to make this a thing
everybody
what we're going to do is going to have
special guest on recorded podcast
from now on we'll have the live show and
then we'll do a special guest show
so you're going to get to see more of me
and more of other people
you know you definitely want to see me
that's why you're here
i mean it is the tony michaels podcast
but we're going to have some special
guest episodes i'm not sure exactly all
the details but we're going to work that
out
but let me get to a video that anthony c
walker the hot medic
post it up on twitter got a lot of views
couple a few hundred maybe a few
thousand
tens of thousands but it's a very
interesting video and i want to ask him
about it when we bring him in but i want
to show it to
you first you have made a decision to
help
governor abbott and being willing to
send some of your national guard troops
to the border
yes so we're sending different state law
enforcement
agencies down there to help stop the
flow of these refugees
coming across our border and that
includes fish and wildlife officers
because
you know these people are animals and
look there's a legal
immigration system that these people can
use but instead they're trying to just
you know come here and say oh i fear for
my life
and i need protection that isn't how
immigration
works but then joe biden turns around
and starts
giving these people visas how is it that
we can give these people credit cards
but we can't even properly fund our own
military
what next he'll be giving them
mastercards and free doctors visits
this is why we're headed down there to
stop the tyranny that is socialism
governor thank you for your time roger
santos pensacola florida thank you
now obviously that is not the real ron
mc dingleberry the governor of florida
obviously it's not it is it is anthony c
walker but let's bring him in and ask
him how the hell does he even do that
hey anthony how's it going buddy howdy
y'all
just up here living in canadia canadia
huh
hey well that's good so how did how does
this video work how do you i mean
obviously this is a real interview with
fox news right
uh yeah so the interview the anchors
those are real that was a real
conversation that they had with ron
desantis
and essentially i just have some editing
software on my computer
and every time that like wherever ron
was in the video i just put myself there
so he was in that little
square in the beginning and i put myself
there when the video
went big that was when ron was talking
he actually said he was sending fish and
wildlife officers
so i kind of used that and just added on
you know the joke oh these people are
animals
but i just put my video there and um
that chiron was at the bottom
that was saying you know who's talking
etc i just made sure that stayed over
top of my video and deleted everything
else
so you kind of like this format because
i've seen you do a couple of these
videos and they've gone pretty well i
mean how many views did this one have on
twitter
160 150 hey that is that ain't too bad
you're beating me by a lot now now
you you've done a few more of these
because i seen another one where you
were you were
you were doing satire of some other
uh uh politicians or their their their
staff something like that right so this
is going well
uh other than some of your other videos
where you're pretending to be
uh a q anon maga trump humper
right uh well recently yes
so the best ever video that i had was
when i did the uh
million mega march uh pretending that i
was there and you know asking where
everyone was that one was
that's about 900 000 views right now um
but you know after biden's inauguration
views for that kind of stuff kind of
started to drop down so i've had to
transition a little bit
so yeah these ones where it's
looking like an actual news interview
those tend to do a little bit better
awesome well i'm excited and anyone who
wants to
go see anthony's content because he does
it and and you confuse a lot of people
uh what what
what did you because because a lot of
times you're confusing liberals
because they're not sure if you're
because let's be honest the the q anon
moga type sometimes when they're
saying stuff you're like surely this
person isn't serious
maybe they are maybe they're not so tell
tell me what you
said about about when liberals think
your content when you're actually a
trump bumper
yeah okay so um i will preface this by
saying that
i i noticed when i was on tech talk and
i by the way i've been banned
i've had two accounts banned on tick
tock so i'm on my third one now i keep
getting reported by liberals thinking
i'm real
um so what i said was you know
unfortunately i prove every single day
with my stuff that
libtards are actually a real thing
i mean if you're on tech talk for
example so my second account
went uh it got permabanned as soon as uh
my first video on there went viral which
was only like the third video i posted
it was within 10 days of me starting the
account
and the video was i was dressed up so i
had my
plate carrier on and i had a police
patch on it and uh
i had a bulletproof helmet on so i
looked like a like a swat
officer kind of thing and
in the in the middle of the screen big
letters it said if
cops spoke honestly and at the bottom it
said this is probably what they would
say
and it was you know tagged hashtag
comedy hashtag satire
and as soon as that started going viral
i was
mass reported and banned and it was all
the amount of hate in the comments from
that video and it was all from the left
all of it was from the last of course it
was of course why you know
you know why you know why you confuse
liberals i mean it's
it really it it makes a little throw up
in my mouth that you're on my show and
you got a trump hat and a trump poster
behind you
i mean most liberals like how can you
even stand to put this [ __ ] on your wall
behind you so yeah i i get why they
they i mean and if you watch tick tock
and if you get on the wrong side of tic
toc
uh you know the the trump pumping maga
types
um man there is not a lot of things
that you say that they would sometimes
they wouldn't say
to be serious or you know i do you
really think they're serious though
do you do you think they're serious with
some of this q anon stuff that some of
the stuff they say
or do you think this is all to what you
said to own libtards
i mean what's your opinion of that
i've seen enough of this [ __ ] to know
that they are
they believe this and so
i mean i'm not even just talking like on
tech talk you can see it enough if you
go if you get into the right places and
start watching right videos
but i've also been to you know telegram
gab clout hub and then there are
different uh
message boards out there q and on
message boards that are you know
on the fringier side of things and i
even
actually posted a picture onto twitter a
while back of it was
um a picture that included a bunch of
stuff
that they actually believe in and i
wonder if i can email you this
quickly so you can post it up on the
screen here for people to see
and we won't be able to talk about all
of it it's just
if there's too much but it's nuts like
they talk about
underground naval bases in antarctica
um jump gates to mars
like not everyone believes all this but
some of them do
and it's scary yeah but but but do you
really think they believe it or do you
think they're just trolling
it's it's just it's because because
here's i have a friend and he and i used
to like professional wrestling when i
was a kid
and of course i knew that it was fake
but it was fun to pretend that it's real
right
you you know that professional
wrestling's fake you know it's fake you
know they're
i mean what i mean by fake is the
outcomes
right it's it's stages acting now
they're actually you know doing the
moves and
putting on the you know the show and
they're getting hurt they're actually
getting hurt
but it is a performance right so do you
think that's kind they know this
is not real it's just fun to pretend
that it's real
do you think that's some of it some of
them
for sure but there's a lot of like there
was uh what was it was about
it was within the last year i'm gonna go
say 10 months ago
there was a lady that went to she was in
the harbor in new york
and she was looking for a naval ship
where and she
she live streamed this before she was
arrested she was looking for a ship
that she heard from queue or on one of
the queued on sites that had
hundreds of children that were supposed
to be sex slaves in the bottom of this
naval ship
she went to the completely wrong ship
for one but two she tried
i guess violently to get on board and
she ended up being arrested
and obviously there's no kids there like
she live streamed this it wasn't made up
like she had real tears on her face like
i'm going to save these children
she believed it so what you're saying is
you think
a lot of it is you know people are
agitating
and they're trying to get uh naive
maybe not so highly intelligent people
to act on some of their agitation
do you think that's absolutely like i
mean you saw with pizzagate too
right right you know basement of a pizza
parlor that doesn't even have a basement
q anon q
which is uh honestly probably just some
russian psyop
is preying on people that have
mental issues they probably have you
know
traumatic experiences like the lady that
relates
or that wants to go save the you know
sex slave children
in the ship she probably has some kind
of
traumatic sexual experience as a child
so she's vulnerable
vulnerable to that and she wanted to go
you know she's essentially trying to
save herself
if you think of the psychology of it so
absolutely
they get preyed upon so so
because i i'm with you here because um
i i have a relative that that
doesn't know that they're queueing on
but they are
what i mean by that is they start
reading these little bits of information
and you call it a russian psyop
right but i in my opinion well right
well right i and here's what i think uh
and this is my opinion is that we had
the alt-right movement
in this country and it would they they
deemed themselves not only did people
you know the the the left call them the
alt-right they called themselves they
branded themselves the alt-right
and then a bunch of crusty white dudes
went to charlottesville
got torches and were marching and looked
like nazis
and when they did that they damaged that
word alt-right
so what the right-wing and or a russian
psyop or whatever it actually
is whatever the um not the motive but
the the means to that end
is i think that
they seem that people really believe
this q anon
stuff this maga because because i what i
like to do
is i like to really mold the two
together the maga the q anon
evangelical christians because i believe
that's the only way we get this garbage
to stop
is we we lump them all together so they
start fighting each other which they're
already starting to do
they're starting to fight each other the
proud boys the three percenters the oath
keepers you know that
because they don't because traditionally
right wing groups don't like each other
because one's not extreme is the other
one has a different purpose one has a
different motive
but with trump they were really able to
all gather up in one goddamn spot and
have one
one common purpose which was to spread
white
right wing propaganda and i think
when the alt-right movement ended with
charlottesville
in this country that's when they looked
for another branding to re-brand it
because they always re-brand the fascism
they're always rebranding it
and i think what they did was rebrand it
to this q anon stuff because they really
seen these people
believing this stuff they they they were
like this is perfect we can
we can work in the white supremacy the
right wing stuff right into this q anon
and we can get right into these people's
brains and suck them in
because like i said i have a relative
that believes this queueing on stuff but
they're like i don't believe that q on
stuff i'm like yeah but do you think
this do you think that you think they're
like yeah i'm like
that's [ __ ] queuing on what the [ __ ]
do you think it is
the [ __ ] you think this [ __ ] is of
course that's the dumb [ __ ] that they
post on the internet
that you're reading and you're believing
even though you're not you don't wear
the t-shirt
right you don't wear the t-shirt or the
or the hat
speaking of hats get you a [ __ ] hat
but the point is the point that i'm
trying to make
is that i believe that it's just a
rebranding
of all our alt-right or right-wing or
fascist propaganda
and it really [ __ ] worked really
[ __ ] good
right like there was no other branding
of right wing fascism in this country
that has taken hold so fast so quick
with such an authoritarian figure like
trump
because that is one question that i want
to ask you because you don't live in
this country
uh so so but obviously your country
suffers from the consequences of the
things that our country does because
we're
we're kind of well not kind of we
literally are are tight at the hip
right our economies rely on each other
in some aspects
obviously we have a border together i
mean there's there's a lot of common
interest between
the united states and canada and a lot
of people some people in this country
don't even know that they're two goddamn
separate countries i mean
they they think it's a territory of the
united states or some [ __ ]
right that they got a different flag
with the stupid stupid leaf on it and
they you know oh my god those people up
north you know those snow people right
people are ignorant people are dumb they
don't know they just don't
but so tell me from this perspective of
living in canada
why why the trump um
presidency watching it what well i mean
what inspired you to even start making
the videos about his supporters
and doing satire of his supporters i
mean what about
it made you go hey i need to do some art
about this well um you know in the
beginning
it wasn't it didn't start out with trump
supporters there was
the maybe some of your viewers will
recall seeing this
it went viral there was a an officer
down in
georgia stacy something or other
she was called officer stacy mcmuffin
uh or yeah karen mcmuffin first then
they found out her name so then it was
stacy mcmuffin
um but she wasn't like a police officer
because the police department actually
commented and like nope she's not with
us
so i'm guessing she was like a bylaw
officer but um she uploaded this two
minute long video where she was
outside a mcdonald's and she was like
she was in tears
partially for some of this video she was
crying about how she had to go through
the drive-through and
wait for her food which is like a
totally normal thing to do
and um it wasn't ready when she got to
the window and they said you know pull
up into this spot
so she did she thought it was a good
idea to upload this video where she was
like melting down over not getting
food in time and i thought
she was wearing you know obviously she
wasn't a cop but she was wearing like
cop-like
attire at the time and i saw this when i
was
running some errands i was in the
passenger seat just you know browsing
twitter and i saw this
i'm like oh [ __ ] i got a kevlar vest
upon i can go home and like do a video
and i can make this funny
because i've been thinking about
starting to do videos because i'd seen
um
i'd seen a video on twitter just a few
days before that that was
um these this guy was doing like a
karen parody where um it was something
[ __ ] it was like um just different
things that karen would do
or karen's would do like um
someone was filming inside the car and
he was wearing a wig driving and he
turned over his shoulder he's like hey i
said no fireworks in the car
that kind of stuff so i was like oh [ __ ]
i could i think i could do videos like
that or something similar
so i went home threw on my vest and i
cried about you know i haven't eaten in
like at least 30 minutes i'm really
hungry and they're not bringing me my
food et cetera et cetera
and uh it got like 17 1800 retweets or
something like that a lot of views and
i'm like oh [ __ ] okay people think i'm
funny
all right well okay i guess i'll
you know start doing videos people like
it i like to make people laugh so i did
i don't know three four of those caring
videos and i'm like you know what
i'm missing out on the real good stuff
because the easiest people to make fun
of
in the world at this current time are
trump supporters
so i i also have a had a
tactical plate carrier um so i was able
to you know look like one of those
you know meal team six or um gravy seals
whatever you want to call them
so i went into my car al-qaeda
i went into my car with the plate
carrier on the patches and i uh made
this a
two minute long video about how um
how you know i love trump and i was like
stop making fun of trump
he's my trumpy bear and i loves him
and it fools so many people because like
for the first 35 seconds
like i kept up the bit like you couldn't
you couldn't tell
it was fake until like the 38 second
mark or something like that
so it fooled so many people it did
really good
well well you know so so you said
they're the easiest targets
and and uh i i i believe they are easy
targets
um and what's even an easier target is
the ones who lead them around
uh because they're all over the map you
know i mean don
jr donald trump uh rudy giuliani these
people are all over the map fox news
newsmax on uh they're so easy
to capture their contradiction their
hypocrisy the right wing has never been
so outright fascist and outright
ignorant
uh in our country's history in a long
long time so i i really agree with you
that they are easy easy targets
now you brought up the word you al-qaeda
there's a uh
one of my most favorite videos that i've
ever done because the video you're
talking about with the mcmuffin that was
like your first
one right that was my very first one
right so that's 14.
right so that kind of that kind of
started it all yeah
the one and you probably got your
favorites because i've got my favorites
and you said
the al qaeda one of my favorite videos
anytime don jr is trending i don't give
a [ __ ] why he's trending i don't give a
[ __ ] i just want to play my booger sugar
video that i made of him
and in the video i say that him and
lauren beaubert
are going to start a band called mr nose
whiskey and the
al qaeda band and that is one of
and i don't know how straight to you
from howdy arabia right
right and i don't know i don't know how
i came up with mr nose whiskey and the
al-qaeda band
it just kind of came out and that's and
i love that line
and a lot of people find it they're like
oh my god that's uh mr nose whiskey and
he all kind of been
that's one of my favorite lines in that
video everyone likes the booger sugar
but i
i like the mr nose whiskey and the all
kind of man so that that reminded me of
that
so so so your content has taken off you
have like
almost 70 80 000 followers on twitter
and you got a pretty good now of course
your tick tocks have been banned and
things like that but
that that you know i'll blame that on a
tick tock algorithm and i've got a lot
of tic tac people that watch
uh the podcast and listen to the podcast
so they'll know what you're talking
about the tick tock algorithm
as far as moderation is horrible a lot
of people get tick
kicked off uh political tick-tock has
changed over the last uh you know six
months really since
uh january 6th and some of the coveted
stuff and some of the vaccine stuff
so that's really changed over there
because they've made a lot of those
issues political
which ends up on those videos which
that's what ends up getting stuff banned
but but you have really um
you have several famous people even
follow you on twitter i think george
takai follows you and a few others
um so that that's pretty cool that that
i mean you even got very famous people
retweeting your stuff
uh but what what i mean where do you
want to go with this i mean are
you are you wanting to do stand-up do
you want to continue to do the videos i
mean
is your goal to keep like a right-wing
watch
on these people because i notice you
post a lot of stuff
kind of like patriot takes and some of
the others where you take some of the
right wing stuff that you're seeing off
gab
and some of these other websites and
you're posting it up and be like hey
look at this this is what they're doing
pay attention
pay attention so i mean what what is
your goal i mean
where do you want to go with with what
you're doing
um well i definitely i don't think i'll
be doing stand-up um that's not really
what i do like i'm doing satire so
it's not really like i'm gonna stand up
and no one's gonna come
watch me as you know a right-wing person
um
just say stupid [ __ ] for half an hour
like it's funny for two minutes i don't
know
i don't know
like it's good for and you know i've
talked to some people in the business
um and it's good for a two minute video
or one minute video
but it's one of those things that like
it's a very niche thing
and you know getting people to come out
there for half an hour especially if
you're trying to do this in you know a
bunch of cities
like do a tour like it's it's not really
going to happen realistically
um it could potentially like if i were
to do stand-up
what would potentially happen would be
say if it was like a
15 minute set then it would be like say
12 minutes
of jokes like regular jokes and then
throw on the play carrier hat and then
three minutes of you know
america's proudest boy that type of
thing but um like for now i just want to
end you know end goal would kind of be
uh writing for
a comedy show like stephen colbert or
doing
something like you know the colbert
report which is like they don't have
anything like that right now
so that's kind of you know a hole that
needs to be filled
so so how i mean so is that where you
draw your inspiration and some of this
gab and some of that content to where
you get the satire
or did you draw it from like other other
satirical comedians
i know there's a lot of them uh on
twitter and online
and and you can probably probably give
me a couple of your inspirations if you
have them but i mean
is that where you've drawn it from i
mean where do you get your inspiration
what's your process of writing this
stuff i mean obviously you're like okay
how do i dumb this down okay how do i
done this down okay how do i dumb this
down even farther
yeah i know that's where we're at with
these people but i mean what is your
process
where do you grab your inspiration i
mean if with your writing of the content
um well yeah some of it does come from
like actual trump supporters there was
one video
where i had said um and i swear this was
like an
actual thing that i saw on tech talk um
there was one video where i had i had
said that i was with the redneck mafia
nation
and you know we were coming if biden won
the election that
kind of thing like redneck mafia nation
is something that like was actually said
by a trump supporter
on tick tocks i'm like yeah i'm gonna
take that and run with it
um but it's obviously
redneck mafia nation that's like you can
say that in a second you need to fill
out the rest of the minute of the video
um so i try and look for things that are
currently trending
and kind of just sit down and think okay
well
what's the stupidest part of this how
can i point out the idiocy
in a way that can make people laugh
because in some of my videos
i don't do joke after joke after joke a
joke
what i like to do is point out the
stupidity of their arguments
more so than just tell a basic joke
like for example the video that we
showed on the way in here
where i was pretending to be ron
desantis when i had said
these people come here claiming they
fear for their life and they want
protection that's not how immigration
works
that is exactly how immigration works
but they still don't want people coming
here do they doing this
like that's how you apply for asylum
refugee status so you feel
fear for your life based on you know
whatever you're gay your
etc that type of thing that is exactly
how that works and but
these people just don't want to say well
we don't want them coming here because
they're black or
brown so they have to come up with
something else i want to point out that
idiocy
but also kind of make it funny so where
he was saying fish and wildlife officers
when i first heard him say that i'm like
what the [ __ ] these they're not animals
that are coming across the border
that'll make for a good joke but these
people aren't animals why are you
sending fish and wildlife officers
well that's because he's a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] i mean that's
that's why and ron desantis knows
exactly why
how immigration works he knows exactly
how
how voting works he knows exactly how
voter intimidation works
that's why he's doing all that garbage
it's because these [ __ ] fascists know
all this stuff
that and and and and you know back to
our what we were
saying about earlier that i believe that
it is
the right wing the fascist alt-right
whatever whatever uh branding that they
currently have
that's why they they cow tower to trump
because trump is the ultimate q anon
pied piper
and the reason why he's a q anon pi
piper is because that [ __ ] idiot
will say anything that they want him to
say he
literally i don't think there is
anything that trump would not say
to make the maga cuanon trump bumpers
cheer like he will say he will say
anything he doesn't care what it is he
doesn't care what the consequences are
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he just
wants the tail has always wagged the dog
in other words
he's never been their leader they've led
him around to tell him what he's
supposed to say
i mean i don't know who feeds him this
garbage i don't know if he's like on gab
trolling around or what like you know
like some people are trying to see what
he's supposed to say and the code
and the language that he's supposed to
talk in but
he did a lot of this with the birtherism
with obama he learned a lot of this
language and this code
when he started with the birtherism with
obama he learned
this language and and he continued this
right-wing nazi languages maybe
for all intents and purposes i mean he's
always been a fascist but
you know that's that that he's never
tried to hide that
he's never just like he doesn't try to
hide that he's a criminal he doesn't try
to hide that
i like this tax return i mean we're
recording this so they haven't indicted
anybody yet now
we've gotten word that that the
manhattan d.a is possibly going to
indict people this week which by the
time this airs there's possibility that
either the trump organization or people
in the trump organization are indicted
on charges in the state of new york and
out of the manhattan da's office
but i don't think he's some sort of
criminal that it doesn't want to be
known as a criminal
what i think what i think is that his
tax returns is going to show he's a
[ __ ] broke [ __ ]
and he doesn't it'll destroy this i'm a
rich businessman image
that he's cultivated for years and years
and years and he's absolutely destroyed
with his horrible business decisions
his horrible financial decisions just
like all the other decisions that he
makes are horrible
uh and and it's it's continued to erode
away
at what fortune his dad gave him and he
doesn't want people to know that
because he doesn't want to ruin his
image so
back to ron desantis i think
i think he's part of the tail wagging
the trump dog
and they know that they can get the rest
of the tail to follow that dog if they
keep wagging it
so the more the more disgusting the more
the grosser the more fascists they get
outright
because that's what these people want
that's what these q anon maga
trump bumping people that go to these
rallies and cheer and
yell and scream and fly the flags and
have the posters behind them on the
wall and have this stupid [ __ ] trump
hats
up on their printer you know those types
of people
those types of [ __ ] people yeah
and and i'm sure we could talk about
political yeah right
i'm sure we could talk about political
issues all day long like medicare
immigration
and i know you being in canada we could
probably talk all day long
about health care and maybe we should
make i'll have you back on and we'll
talk about those
issues um but i do i do want to ask you
one more thing before we go and i want
to talk about one more thing
because i seen something on twitter or
somewhere
where someone had gone in and hacked
your account or something and
maybe it had to do with anonymous maybe
it didn't
i'm not sure you know plausible
deniability here
but there are there is some word out
there that possibly you were hacked by
anonymous or
you're pretending to maybe you maybe
your cue
maybe your cue and we just don't know it
so tell me about
the hacking that ensued on your on your
account tell me about that
uh yeah so anonymous um
for anyone watching that doesn't know
anonymous is uh well they've been
branded as digital terrorists in the
past
there's honestly too much for me to tell
you in the time that we have so
just type it anonymous look it up make
your own decisions basically
they're trying to you know unfuck the
world as best they can
um with the means that they have
available which
is less than cyber security is a lot
better now so it's you know less than
they have
had before but um right now one of the
biggest things they
they're using is twitter so for example
the
in india when they were cutting out the
um
the internet in india there were a few
people that
decided to hack the indian government
um so that occurred there's the stuff
that's going on in israel so they have
operation israel running right now
um they're trying to you know publicly
let everyone know through twitter what's
going on there the reporting on like um
the journalist being arrested for
example for nothing except for
actual factually reporting um but
i'm actually friends with these people
uh really good friends we have a lot of
fun
uh the person that started anonymous
turns he's from toronto i'm
from outside toronto but he now lives
only 25 minutes for me we're best
friends um
we he comes over for dinner every week
we hit the atv trails
or used to be every weekend but uh
recently he flipped my atv
and he uh nearly broke his ankle it's
it was two weeks ago and it's not
looking good
but as far as the hacking my account
thing
um that was my friend john jackson who'd
replied and uh he had
he texted me and he said hey send me a
picture of you go to
your account hit edit profile and just
send me that picture
so i did so he posted he's like oh i
hacked his account i can edit stuff now
and everything
so yeah it's all in good fun we're
having a really good time um
one of the admins from the you're not
news account
which that's they have 7 million roughly
7 million followers there
um she was in on it too and um
she was saying we're gonna aim all
loic's
anthony c walker little orbit ion cannon
look it up
internet geeky hacky thing um and then
said oh now we've doxed him here's his
phone number and uh the phone number
actually
led to a rick astley hotline uh where
you could hear the song never going to
give you up
so yeah it was it was hilarious
uh that was one of the funnest days i've
had on twitter in a long time
we trolled so many people actually we
even trolled another one of the
admins for the url news account because
i got a message like um
we were in the middle of doing all this
trolling right and then i got a message
from them on twitter and say hey anthony
sorry um you know all the stuff that
just happened that was from a moderator
that didn't know you were comedian
again sorry i deleted all these tweets
and like
so i i went and chatted uh we used an
encrypted messaging app uh this other
admin that i talked to and i sent
her the picture of this and i said
i don't think they know that we're just
having fun here um
so the next thing i see in the messages
on twitter from
your non-news was hey whoever this is
because they have multiple moderators
whoever this is you just got trolled by
your own team we're just having fun here
don't delete messages in the future
without permission i was like oh [ __ ]
oops oopsie oopsie
well uh i hope uh now that i've had you
on here and you're talking about this
[ __ ] because i know nothing about it
that i'm not hacked and
people don't come after me well i mean
you know what you know what even if they
do
[ __ ] them i i don't [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
i don't care
they're gonna hack your camera and make
you look like trump for all your future
videos oh well you know that that could
that
i hear they have that technology so but
uh actually
you know what maybe i'll maybe i'll
reveal this here on your podcast for the
first time ever
that technology is called deep fake
technology and i'm currently
investigating the use of that so that i
might portray myself
as a certain senator
or congressman woman etc something like
that
uh oh uh oh we have plans of future
content being revealed here on the
[ __ ]
podcast the tony michaels podcast is now
reporting breaking news
anthony c walker is going to be using
deep fake to portray someone
in the near future in his content check
that [ __ ] out so tell him anthony
where can you find that content tell
them about tell them about where we can
find this [ __ ]
okay twitter at anthony c walker uh
instagram and youtube is bulletproof
medic
for tick tock i'm on my third account
there now so it's
the bulletproof medic is what i'm
currently on i mean by the time this
airs they could ban that it might be on
the fourth account who knows
either way either way we'll we'll drop
all those all your handles down
into the description here in the video
uh
anthony i appreciate you coming on today
and talking to me about the q anon maga
trump bumpers
i appreciate you uh using satire to show
the world how
really ignorant these people are rather
it be the q and honors themselves the
karens of the world or the ron
dingleberry governors of the world and
possibly
possibly it sounds like with new deep
fakes
that we may get some more anthony c
walker
content so i appreciate you coming on
here we're gonna have are you on in the
future
so keep making your content and we'll
have you on we'll play more of your
content here we'll talk more about
medicare
immigration reform and maybe maybe
have a conversation more about this q
and on trump bumper thing you know
if it lasts you know if it lasts
for us all to talk about it so thank you
anthony thanks for joining us
say bye everybody see you anthony
all right so that was anthony c walker
thanks
for the bullet proof medic the hot medic
joining me here on the tony michaels
podcast
what'd you guys think you should go
check out his content he's got he's got
a lot of stuff now i know i know his
tick tock accounts got taken down and by
the time this airs like he said he may
have another one taken down
but he's got several videos over there
uh you can find his stuff on twitter i
know he's on youtube and we'll put all
those links down below
so go go check out his content see what
you think now
again he's not really he's not
really a q a mega trump upper so take it
easy
you might give him a little bit of hell
in the comments just for shits and
giggles but you know
that's just me i like the [ __ ] with
people
but thanks for joining us and next week
we'll be back live
next week live three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern right here on
youtube we're also streaming on twitch
i haven't figured out what the hell
twitch is yet it's been several weeks i
think this is like the sixth show we've
been on twitch and
i still don't know what the hell that
thing is but we're over there go check
it out we're over there and we stream on
twitter
to all the twitter people out there
we're streaming on twitter
and if you don't catch it live don't
worry
don't worry as soon as we're done it's
gonna go
be posted on on apple podcast on spotify
that way all the people out there that
don't want to look at my ugly mug they
can listen to it
but today's episode with anthony will be
available
on all the podcast directories whichever
one you like
it'll be there you just go look for it
and you go to link in the bio on
thetonymichaels.com and find them and if
you want to support the podcast
other than just listening we got [ __ ]
stickers you guys like the [ __ ]
stickers and the [ __ ] hats so go to
thetonymichaels.com
if you want to support the podcast that
way otherwise
otherwise [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime
follow tony on social media at the tony
michaels
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them